Now that we know how to send a variable over the network. Let's take a look at how we can send a function of the network
much like with propagating variables the reflection system does a lot of the heavy lifting here a
Remote procedure call or RPC is a method of calling a function on one or more remote clients or the server
We can go from the client to the server or from the server to a specific client
As long as we're calling the function from an object that's ultimately owned by the player controller
Each player controller represents the network's connection between the client and the controlling server with no player controller
We're unable to pick out a particular client to send a message to
Multicasts however are sent from the server to every connected client and as such require no player controller to be involved
Defining a function to be called over the network is as easy as flagging a function with the U function markup and
Supplying the appropriate specifiers in our case here
We've got a multicast function being sent out reliably and with some required validation when calling it
We'll cover the multicast in just a second
But a quick note on reliability and validation if we call an RPC reliably
We flag into the engine that this function must go through to receiving clients. It doesn't matter if it's late
It just needs to reach them as gameplay engineers. We can't just ignore a gameplay critical function call
So flagging a function as reliable ensures that the function will be called regardless of lag
We can also flag something as unreliable which essentially outlines functions that are cosmetic or non gameplay critical
If we hit a patch of lag just after calling this function
We don't need to worry about it being received as much as we would with a reliable function
Validation allows us to assess whether or not a networked function is what we expect it to be
If we return false from the validate function, the requesting client will be booted from the server
So consider the following the client presses reload sending a reload call to the server
If the amount that they want to reload by in a single call is greater than say a single bullet
We can assume they found some kind of exploits or work around and boot them from the server before they have any meaningful impact
As for the actual function definition, we actually have three separate functions that we need to implement
Firstly, we've got our base you function written here as multicast to do function. This is just a stub function
It doesn't require any implementation directly
Then we have an explicitly defined
Implementation function for the networking subsystem to call once it receives the call over the network
And this is the main function where we put our gameplay code. This is the body that contains our implementation
We then have a validate function that holds our RPC validation and certification code as we mentioned above if we omit the with
Validation specifier the compiler won't prompt us to add a validate function
RPCs come in three flavors
First we've got server functions and this function when called on the client will execute the body on the server
This will only work if the object that we're calling the RPC from is owned by the local player controller
Next we've got client when called on the server. The body of this function will be executed client-side
Much like a server call a client call also needs to be called from an object owned by a player controller
This player controller dictates what client the body is actually executed on
Lastly we've got multicast and this function is fired everywhere
That's locally on the server as well as on all relevant clients
If the client is out of relevancy, the RPC will still be sent but not received